في الجبهات الشماليه من مقاطعه دونيزك
تستعين القوات الاوكرانيه بمدافع روسيه
الصنع لنشرها في المناطق القريبه من
البلدات التي استرجعتها مؤخرا
تسعى هذه الوحدات كما يقول القاده
الميدانيون الى الحاق الضرائب القوات
الروسيه واستهداف في مخازن الاسلحه وخطوط
الامداد وتشكيل خط رابع لاي محاولات
لاسترجاعها
الان لا نتصدى للهجمات بل نحرص على ان لا
تشن ايون منها وان لا يفكر العدو بالتقدم
من هنا اعتقد ان اعمالنا ساهم في عوده
الناس الى مدننهم
[تصفيق]
تشمل هذه النقاط مدينتي لمن وصفته ريسك
اللتين استعادهما الجيش الاوكراني اواخر
سبتمبر ماضي
يقول الجيش الاوكراني انه يتصدى لهجمات
الجيش الروسي في محاور ويسترجع
فما هو حال المدن والبلدات المسترجعه في
ظل ظروف الشتاء هذه السيده ذات السبعين
عاما بقيت في مدينه اليمن اكبر الحواضر
المسترجعه مؤخرا
اوه كتموت انستالي
لكن التدفئه والمياه متوقفتان لك ان تتخيل
المعاناه مع البرد القارس تساعدنا الحكومه
في تقديم بعض الفحم لكن علينا جمع الحطب
من الغابه بانفسنا اعيش مع زوجي على راتب
التقاعد فقط لكن لا خيار لابد للحياه ان
تستمر
الحياه حفرت بئرا للحصول على الماء فالحرب
لم تترك لها خيارات كثيره
يشهد الدمار الكبير على براوه المعارك
التي جرت في المدينه ومع ذلك يقيم فيها
عدد لا باس به من السكان
عوده الناس الى هنا بالرغم من صعوبه
الظروف
كشفت كذلك عن مساوئ اخرى للحرب
بعد ان فقدوا احبائهم في ما يعاني اخرون
فقرا وفاقا سيحتاج التخلص
لمواصله القتال عمر الحاجه الجزيره من
مدينه اليمن